programming throwdown episode 155 the future of search with sahil jain take it away patrick excited to be here for another episode. 155. I don't know. I guess we can, we remark on the number every time, but that habit, that habit. We should, we should hire someone to help write intros for us. Oh no, that's what we're going to get chat GPT to do. Oh, I should hire a ghostwriter. I was listening to a podcast where they were talking about getting researchers and then the researchers would basically feed them all their topics. And I was like, we've been doing this a very long time, Jason, but we've never been that professional. No, never happened.
I don't even know if we discussed it. Is it true that musicians don't write their own songs? Or is that just like a diss or something? It depends on the musician. Okay, that's a very good, very noncommittal answer. Is it true that Stack Overflow writes all your code, Jason? Yes. All right.
Well, we're going to welcome to the show Sahil. He is an engineer at u.com. Glad to have you here. Yeah, glad to be here. So the way we always kind of start this off with guests, you know, it's always an interesting story to learn a little bit about the different ways people got into tech, got into programming. So do you have like a first memory, like a first computer, or first time you did a programming problem, or was like the earliest thing that sort of
got you excited about technology? Yeah, that's a good question. So actually, I think compared to most folks, especially nowadays, I probably got introduced to programming a little bit later compared to most folks. I never actually did much programming in middle school or even high school, for that matter. I think the first kind of introduction I got was really in college. Really, I think what I initially wanted to do was become more of a mechanical engineer. So I was, you know, in high school and stuff, I was really interested in physics. So I thought in some ways I would maybe focus on, you know, going down the applied physics or just physics engineering. But then I think I realized very quickly that I wasn't super good with my hands,
but I was much better at, you know, dealing with the world of abstractions. So I think I naturally gravitated a bit towards programming. I think the first memory was working on a project where i was using a very simple you know nearest neighbor classification algorithm to determine whether a cell is malignant or benign okay i think that was kind of a really fun experience because i think it showed me how you know useful and powerful programming can be and kind of a really fun experience because I think it showed me how useful and powerful programming can be. And it was a really simple thing. You just basically look at the different attributes of a cell and you match it to the nearest kind of cell you have in your data set. And you can see whether or not that one was willing or benign and then classify this one.
And you can benchmark the scores. I just remember that being one of my first core experiences. Yeah, I mean, I think that's pretty good. You know, I think it's interesting, you're right, a lot of folks do have experiences a lot earlier. And so the, I don't want to say sophistication, that sounds insulting. The level of complexity of the thing that they get exposed to when they start programming is a lot, a lot lower, just because, you know, when you're, like you said, you know, a middle schooler or an elementary student, you know, you can be exposed to a lot of programming ideas, but you don't have the math background. So for you to say, you know, so it's simple,
you look to your neighbors, I mean, even describing, you know, what the nine connected neighborhood is, or your eight neighbors, and like trying to express how in a Cartesian space, you know, one might be up or up into the right, you know, explaining that to someone, you know, I have a fifth grader. So explaining that to my fifth grader, like she gets it, but she doesn't really get it. And so, you know, the complexity at which you can sort of like, touch on the variety of subjects that programming really involves. I think it's a great story. I don't know if you were doing an actual malignant detection thing or whether it was a sort of like a simplified cell version with attributes but either way i mean just like a great a great topic oh yeah this is totally a toy problem okay all right it's not real this is not real at all this is getting the first programming assignment type thing i was going to
be impressed you had like open cv open and you were like looking at microscopy slides and a dye stain and trying to i was going to be like, that's a pretty high bar for first programming problem. No, no, not at all. No, no, that's still good. But yeah. And, you know, you touched on as well, mechanical engineering. And I think it's often forgotten by me, like even when I was in school, mechanical engineers still had to do a lot of programming.
They get exposed to it. And even the CAD software today has a lot of scripting or procedural elements that aren't that dissimilar. But as you said, I think there are some folks who sort of think they want to do one thing and switch to the other or back and forth. Very, very common. So you you were doing this first programming assignment, you got really engaged, presumably in a class where and then you just sort of like decided to kind of like pursue that more, like take more classes? Yeah, I think at that time, I was still unsure. For me, I think I, I probably decided a little bit later, even after that. But yeah, I think essentially, I was kind of exploring different topics in parallel, I knew I was in the I was basically
an engine in the engineering school, which, you know, limited the options a little bit. But I was very interested in energy systems and that type of stuff at the time as well, which I still am. More as a side hobby, I guess. But yeah, so I think, you know, I think I realized that, yeah, I guess, you know, programming is fun, just the joy of it. And in general, building software. I think the idea of artificial intelligence also always appealed to me. I think that was really what kind of drew me towards programming is kind of the appeal of, you know, building intelligent systems.
So that's really kind of the route that drew me in. I guess we could hit the energy systems. I'm not sure exactly what you meant, but I feel like we can summon a discussion about thorium at this point, just do like the tech hipster topics like thorium ai like this is the this is the classic thing so i don't know we don't have to we don't have to go in there but is that energy systems you know you say you're in a hobby that's sort of like energy plant productions or oh sorry i said intelligent systems oh intelligent systems oh i'm sorry oh never mind i'm just excited i want to talk about thorium see that's the
all right cool never mind well i just ignored that uh we'll keep going keep going on uh is that the same as tiberium no that's coming to conquer yeah oh okay i i do remember talking to uh to someone else about thorium a while back yeah i wonder what happened to that i remember there was a lot of excitement there no no no i no. I can't. I can't. All right, ho. We've got to keep going.
Yeah, yeah. Look it up. Look it up. There's YouTube videos. YouTube videos. Thorium. It's good stuff. No, don't get near it.
Don't get near it. But read about it. It's fine. So, yeah. So you got this interest in programming. And then did you end up, you know, when you sort of graduated school, did you take your first job as like a programming job or wasn't sort of at that level yet? Yeah. So when I was deciding, I was actually deciding.
I remember for, I guess, my first job, I was deciding between, I guess, a couple of startups and then Microsoft as well. Some of them were engineering roles. Some of them were product roles. I actually ended up for my first role entering as a product manager at Microsoft where I was working on, I guess, cloud infrastructure and Office 365. Oh, very nice. I don't know if it's still the case. People may not know. So we have a little bit differently than a lot of other software and that they have tight couple teams where you said like product managers, software engineers and at a time test engineers. Is that still was that still the sort of arrangement that they had going or is that something that they've sort of gone past? Yeah, I mean, I guess when I was there, which is also, I guess, a little bit of time ago at this point. But I think it really depends on the team within the company. I think at a big company like Microsoft, it's almost like you're working at a different company depending on what org you're on. And the structures are radically different across different teams.
The team I was on, I remember we did have a little bit of that set up. We had a lot of service engineers because we were more on the cloud infrastructure side. So we had software engineers, service engineers, and product managers. Nice. And so you were doing product management, but still had your eye on wanting to do more of a programming role and continue to do that?
Or how did it sort of shape up in your time in that role? Yeah, so I mean, I've always been interested in building things as well as in whatever form it may take. So. I mean, I've always been interested in, you know, building things as well as in whatever form it may take. So I think the way I've always viewed it is there's a bunch of different roles. If somebody's interested in tech, there's definitely a lot of different ways to contribute, one of which is engineering, but one of which is, you know, design. There's a whole host of, you know, cool ways to contribute, even if you're not necessarily
inclined to code or to engineer necessarily. But I think for me, I was always, you know, working on side projects or, you know, interested in writing code in addition to kind of, I guess, my day job at that time. So I think in some ways, I necessarily didn't really identify myself as a product manager as an engineer, but more just, you more just in the spirit of building products, whatever that may be. And then I think I ended up again kind of returning to kind of being interested in artificial intelligence.
So I think immediately after Microsoft, I ended up becoming a researcher. So I ended up, I guess, doing research at Stanford in a machine learning group. And I think that was a pretty important experience for me and kind of helped me, you know, better understand what I'm interested in. Nice. That's a pretty big transition, right?
To work for Microsoft and then go to be a researcher at Stanford. How did that sort of come about? Yeah, so I ended up going to grad school. So I think the way it came about was, I think in some sense, I was always interested in, you know, artificial intelligence. And I guess a little bit of at the time, I was also very interested in healthcare. And I still am. So I think healthcare and search, there's fascinating interactions between the two of them. And I think there's a lot of work to be done in improving health search. But really, I think I came in with the angle of I wanted to, you know, use AI to improve healthcare. I think there's a lot of different ways healthcare is broken. And I was also interested in language. So natural language processing has always been kind of of interest to me. So I think I ended up doing research kind of at the intersection of the two. A lot of it was, you know, how can we use, you know, language to improve health, whether that
means, you know, mining, you know, reports for label data to then train, you know, language to improve health, whether that means, you know, mining, you know, reports for label data to then train, you know, computer vision models for healthcare, to just thinking a little bit more about, you know, conversational agents in healthcare and, you know, bias, etc. So I think that was kind of what drew me. It was more just an interest in topics. I think the topic in that case was just artificial intelligence, natural language processing, like deep learning, healthcare, those types of, it was a little bit varied, but that's kind of the general. Yeah. And so what did you, what did you kind of pursue while you were there? What kind of research were you doing? Yeah. So I guess I was doing research. Yeah,
I guess at the intersection of healthcare and deep learning. Okay. So I guess, you know, some of the projects I ended up working on, I guess maybe the first one was, it was a project called Chexbert, which we ended up releasing. And essentially what that was is it was a radiology report labeling tool that, you know, used, at this time I think BERT was, it wasn't necessarily new, but it was maybe like one or two years after BERT. And a lot of the existing radiology report labelers were very heuristic based, which means they use like a lot of, you
know, hard coded rules, essentially. And they were being used to train a bunch of computer vision models, some of which were being tested in hospitals. So the idea was that, you know, we can very easily improve the quality of the labels, which will then downstream improve all the other models that are trained on the labels using kind of some of the advances in natural language processing. So we ended up kind of developing Chexpert, which we released. And, you know, it was a great project
and, you know, it's been used by other researchers for their projects in different ways. So I think that was kind of one flavor of research. The other one was building data sets. So I think I gained a lot of appreciation for, you know, how important data is in machine learning and AI. Like one of the datasets we built was called RadGraph.
Essentially it was basically a dataset of entities and relations and radiology reports annotated at more of a fine-grained level than previous datasets in that healthcare space. And the idea was that it can eventually help train multimodal models when matched with computer vision images. So that was kind of a couple flavors of work. And there were some other along those lines. Nice. So it may be obvious to many folks, but humor me, it's not obvious to me. So Jason's background is more machine learning by now. But you mentioned something here that I've heard. So I'll get your opinion on it, or maybe you can help me on this. So you mentioned, you know, looking at radiology reports and doing natural language processing.
When you say that, do you mean, and you mentioned like sort of computer vision as well. Are you looking at the sort of like scans of a radiology, like an x-ray? Or are you looking at like the human text that like a radiologist would enter? Yeah, that's a great question. And yeah, I think I was breezing through. So no, no, no, that's okay. No, no, that's why I definitely have clarified a bit more, because I definitely think it's not obvious now that I've said it. But essentially, I think what I was looking at was, in this context, the human written text. So oftentimes, when a radiologist, you know, looks at their patient or their x rays, they'll then write down clinical
notes. So in general, I was paying a lot of attention to clinical notes that doctors are writing, and how to essentially structure that information. Because it's fascinating, there's all these notes that we have that we've collected, you know, doctors have made over, you know, the course of decades, and it's all very unstructured. And when you have unstructured data that's in free text, it's very hard to use it for analytics, insights, training machine learning models. So there's a lot of value we can just get by structuring a lot of the data in healthcare. So that's kind of maybe the theme of the research a little bit is how can we, how can we leverage, you know, all these like decades of knowledge that doctors have inputted? How can we structure that and then use it to, you know, be a little bit more algorithmic in the future? Nice. Well, I was going to tee up
a question about natural language processing and maybe large language models and like diverse fields that aren't related to text. But this is also interesting. So we'll dig in on this one. And maybe we can get back to that later at some other point, if it comes back up again. But so you mentioned this, and you know, we hear this as well, a little bit in the in the machine learning, this taking unstructured text, right? So a radiologist writes what they I, please correct me if I'm wrong. But like, they sort of write in, you know, notes about, hey, I looked at this patient's chart, maybe they were given something that they were looking to try to diagnose. And then they're sort of writing, it's all freeform prose, almost, you know, I guess I would say, like, oh, I see that, you know, there's this thing here, or that thing there, it looks
like this, it could be that maybe follow up suggestions would be to do this or that, you know, or, you know, I deem it's okay. And this is very unstructured. And you mentioned sort of making it more, you know, hierarchical. You also mentioned sort of entities and relationships and sort of like some of these modeling. And as you were saying, some of it may have been previously like heuristic based, like searching, I assume for sort of keywords saying this keyword corresponds to that keyword. Therefore in this chart, there's like this entity of, you know, a specific kind of growth. I don't know the word. And it relates to this patient and this over here. And you're sort of saying just giving it to a machine learning, you know, rather than heuristic and allowing it to just sort of build those relationships.
What does that end up is maybe that's too broad of a question. What does it end up looking like you feed them text and the training I assume is the sort of desired model output of like the hierarchy that you expect from from that text, and you're asking it to sort of do the same thing? Yeah, yeah, that's a good question. And I think in some ways, when I say structure, clinical information, the North Star is to capture all of the meaning and all of the nuance in a clinical note. But there's a lot of work until we can kind of do that. So the way we started off was very simple. And we, you know, used existing schemas that, you know, our lab had actually developed. In this case, it was called like the Chexpert report and schema.
And really it consisted of like 14 different labels for different conditions. So this was kind of, you know, formed with a lot of interaction between, you know, machine learning researchers and also doctors. And it was basically, you know, a very simple task, you know, given a report, what are the positive, negative or absent mentions of a particular medical condition? So for example, pneumonia, pneumothorax, cardiomegaly, these are all examples of different medical conditions. And there was maybe, you know, a couple of labels, different labels that each of those conditions can have. And that was kind of the setup of the problem. And then in terms of how we trained it, really, this is also kind of
another interesting thing is that we actually use a lot of these heuristic systems in order to generate labels. And we actually train some of these, you know, more powerful models using kind of models from or labels from simpler models. So this is kind of known in machine learning as generally kind of, you know, weekly supervised learning, where you can kind of have, you know, noisy labels, essentially, and you can learn off of them. And then you can have a stronger set of high quality labels that were, you know, devised by radiologists, and then you fine tune on those, and then you end up getting better performance than the initial labeler that you even used for training. So in some ways, it's kind of like a student teacher model, where the student ends up ultimately outperforming the teacher. It's kind of one maybe way of thinking about it. Nice. Yeah, I hear that as like a recurring thing now where rather than sort of a homogenous
training supervised, you know, this data set in and then I just get my results out where like you're kind of mentioning, you may have an earlier stage that uses one approach for training. And then you mentioned sort of like refinement, but like, you know, kind of mixing and matching different training styles throughout the sort of larger, larger model seems to be a, something I see at least as a, as a layman and not in the machine learning space as something that I see as a recurring theme more recently. So that's interesting. Yeah, yeah, no, I mean, it's a, there's a lot of interesting work going on. All right. So you're not at Stanford now. So something happened after that. So you did your research, you got your degree, and then where did you go next? Yeah. So I guess while I was doing research and I was becoming interested in language
and natural language processing, at that point in time, you know, towards, I guess, the end and maybe overlapping a little bit, I had started working with u.com. So our founders, Brian and Richard, were both previously at Salesforce, which is kind of this, you know, I guess a big tech company. And then they had kind of a vision of starting a search engine. So I know Richard has been thinking of starting a search engine for a while. And he had left Salesforce at that time with Brian. And I think I had noticed somewhere that, you know, that they, you know, that they had, you know, posted about it. And I think I had reached out or maybe they had reached
out by some like alumni or whatever. And ended up, you know, joining and, you know, helping build u.com. And, you know, there was definitely a lot of like, you know, interesting problems, and there still is in the search space, which I think is what attracted me. So I think making the jump from research to working at a startup was something that felt a little bit natural, especially given the fact that it was such a, you know, ambitious problem. So I think that's something that appealed to me is the idea of working on something that, you know, is hard. It's definitely not easy to build a search engine, especially when, you know, it's a, there's a lot of people who, you know, have a good product out there. Google's a great product. So, but we thought that, you know, we can,
out by some like alumni or whatever. And ended up, youening, you know, joining and, you know, helping build u.com. And, you know, there was definitely a lot of like, you know, interesting problems, and there still is in the search space, which I think is what attracted me. So I think making the jump from research to working at a startup was something that felt a little bit natural, especially given the fact that it was such a, you know, ambitious problem. So I think that's something that appealed to me is the idea of working on something that, you know, is hard. It's definitely not easy to build a search engine, especially when, you know, it's a, there's a lot of people who, you know, have a good product out there. Google's a great product. So, but we thought that, you know, we can,
you know, still provide something of value. So I think that's kind of what sold me a little bit on, I guess, moving from academia more into industry slash startup world. Awesome. So, I mean, I think this sort of have an idea of search, you know, the equivalent, I guess, of your hotkey and then letter F for sort of like searching a document for text. We even had an episode where we talked about, you know, how you would do search in databases and this kind of thing. But we sort of not really covering the topic of search engine, right? So something where you're going to a website and trying to index all of publicly or maybe even not publicly accessible human information that's up on the web and allowing people to sort of find the needle in the haystack, right? Find the thing
they're looking for. This is my personal, I've no idea this is a very good definition of a search engine. But this is a topic that I think everyone bumps up against at some time. Like you said, we've all used Google or, you know, another search engine and sort of, you know, put in your text. And like you said, there's already, you know, you sort of mentioned your background was natural language processing. There are many pieces to that. I can think of a thousand ways to sort of like start into the conversation. So maybe I'll just, you know, kick it over to you. Like when you think about this space, is there a sort of approach that you think about the sort of high level components of, you know, sort of I type text in a box, or what is a text even look like or formatting to, you know, I get, you know, a link or even just the information that I'm looking for
on the internet? Like, how do you either think about what it is today or think about where you want to see it going? Yeah, yeah. I think, yeah, there's definitely a lot of excitement around search right now. I think search is, in some ways, it's been a little bit, I wouldn't say, I think it's always been evolving over the last couple of decades.
But I think right now is particularly a time when we're seeing almost like a paradigm shift in search, which I can kind of get into in a bit. But in general, like when I think about search, and I think you mentioned search over databases, I think when I think about search kind of in this concept that you're talking about, when we think about, you know, essentially, you know, search engines, I think one of the differences is basically in the types of information that you're searching over and the goals. So I think when you're doing something like a database lookup, you're basically looking over data that's already been, you know, very structured. And you're essentially kind of looking for almost like a very procedural method of finding like an exact match or something.
And I think that definitely has value and is very interesting. In general, when I talk about search, I think about, you know about the discipline most aligned with search would be kind of this area known as information retrieval. And in information retrieval, I think there's a couple characteristics, one of which is we're kind of doing search over a large corpus of data. So if it's a small corpus, it's not really a search problem.
A lot of search engine is the point is that you're searching over kind of like an infinite amount of documents or a very large amount of documents. That's one characteristic that makes it a bit different sometimes than other settings. And then the other one is that these documents tend to be very unstructured. So for example, web pages are super unstructured, information about news, et cetera. So in general, you're looking for unstructured information. There's a lot of it.
That's basically the setting in which search operates. And then in terms of, I think you mentioned, you know, search being about, you know, you type in something, you get some links. I think that's the way it's historically been. And I think, you know, when we look at existing systems, a lot of times it's become kind of very ad dominated. So you end up, you know, searching, you get links and you get links with ads above it. And in general, that's kind of in the paradigm.
And obviously there's been a lot of content as well. if you look at a lot of search engine, there's knowledge panels, etc, with kind of extracted content, which is very useful. But I think what we're going to start seeing is a move towards search being more about getting you the answer and letting you do things. So I just want to bring a search engine, we think about, you know, being a do engine, not just search engine, how can we let you do things to kind of achieve your goals? So that's kind of maybe one distinction that we see search going from. So we kind of see it also as maybe going away from like a list of blue links to a list of kind of, you know, different types of organizations of content. So this can be kind of just giving you the answer straight up. You know, it could be in the form of a chatbot. So
we've been thinking a lot about conversation. So I think we'll see search evolve in many different ways. But yeah, I definitely think we're moving away from the, you know, you search something, you get a bunch of blue links, you click through a bunch of them, and then you eventually find what you're looking for to being a more kind of user centric, like streamlined experience. I was going to just make a funny observation
that getting blue links isn't as bad as searching something and getting the purple links. And you're like, oh, no, I've already tried these. Like, I need new links. So, okay, so blue links is, I get what you're saying. But anyways, I recall, like, I'm thinking back to, you kind of mentioned this, like, if you have a small set of data, it's sort of a different set of problem where small i guess is a is a bit of a relative term
but i recall like early on i guess you know i'm kind of old so like when i would first you know sort of move from a card catalog at the library to like they had a computer and you could look up not just what books were in your library but in ours ours, it's a countywide library where I was growing up. So actually, there was many branches, and you could search and see what books were in stock across the entire library system in that county. And I recall one of the things, one, it was pretty terrible. Two, like you had to put in text that was pretty close to what you were searching for. And then you needed to tell it like, do you want it to search, you know, author, title, subject, like literally in a drop drop down like what field are you searching and then they would give these things which at my time i didn't really know by boolean operators like i want this and this or not this um and so you could sort of say like i want i'm trying to think of a good
但我想起早期的时候，我年纪也算不小了，当我在图书馆第一次从卡片目录换到他们有了电脑的时候，你可以查询的不仅是你们图书馆里有哪些书，还有我们这里的书，那是个全郡的图书馆，我是在那里长大的。所以实际上，那里有很多分馆，你可以搜索并查看整个郡的图书馆系统里有哪些书。我记得其中一件事，首先，那个体验相当糟糕。其次，你输入的文本必须非常接近你要搜索的内容。然后你需要告诉它，你是想搜索作者、标题、主题，简直就像在一个下拉菜单里选择你究竟在搜索哪个字段，接着它们会提供一些我当时其实并不了解的东西，比如布尔运算符，像“我想要这个和这个，或者不要这个”等等。所以你可以说，比如说，我在想一个好
example i want cooking but not food i don't know what that would be. But like, you know, I want, yeah, oh, shoes, but not sneakers. So like, I guess dress shoes or, you know, brake pad shoes. Are there shoes? I don't know. And so like there was this, you know, sort of Boolean, very structured, almost like programming concepts, these logical concepts that you needed to sort of go in and put down into the search box and then run your search. And you know, it would come back with inevitably, basically nothing. But you know, you would try to get one thing. And then you were sort of saying,
例子，我想要烹饪但不要食物，我不知道那会是什么。但就像，你知道的，我想要，哦，鞋子，但不要运动鞋。所以，比如说正装皮鞋，或者，你知道的，刹车片。这世上有这种鞋吗？我不知道。所以有这种，你知道的，所谓的布尔逻辑、高度结构化、几乎就像编程概念一样的逻辑概念，你需要把它们输入到搜索框中，然后运行你的搜索。你知道，它不可避免地会返回基本上什么都没有的结果。但你知道，你会试着得到一样东西。然后你可能会说，
you know, to moving to a more conversational. So I think over time, we've seen a lot of changes where people have moved to, I guess, with sort of Google coming to be there, like, you can type in a word. And it used to be before Google, like you would type in that word, and you would just find websites that had that word repeated, like 1000 times in like white on white at the bottom of the page. And they were just saying, like, frequency, like, which was the most. And then, at least for me, like starting to use Google was like you type in a word and that word didn't even need to appear in the page you were looking for. Like it seemed to try to understand related words or concepts or, you know, what you were searching for. And to sort of I'm
你知道，开始转向一种更加对话式的方式。所以我想随着时间的推移，我们看到了很多变化，人们开始转向，我想随着谷歌的出现，比如你可以输入一个字。在谷歌出现之前，通常的情况是，你输入那个字，然后你只会找到那些把那个字重复了上千次网页，比如在页面底部的白色背景上用白色字体写的。它们只是在谈论词频，也就是哪个词出现最多。然后，至少对我来说，开始使用谷歌就像是你输入一个字，而那个字甚至不需要出现在你正在寻找的页面中。它似乎试图去理解相关的词语或概念，或者你知道的，你到底在搜索什么。为了把我的
giving my own narrative, but feel free to fill in gaps there. But like today, you sort of mentioned now it becomes almost more even conversational. Like I'm not even just typing words, like I'm typing whole questions or sentences in sometimes. Sometimes it works well. Sometimes it doesn't. I feel like often it's just ignoring a lot of the context you're trying to put in your sentence. But, you know, that's sort of, I feel like myself,
故事讲完，不过你们随时可以补充细节。但就像今天，你刚才提到现在它变得几乎更具对话性了。比如我甚至不只是在输入字词，有时候我是在输入整段的问题或句子。有时候它管用，有时候不管用。我觉得它经常会忽略你试图放在句子里的很多上下文。但是，你知道，这就是那种，我觉得我自己，
even how I interact with it, I guess the systems are training us in as much as we train the system, like giving you feedback about the quality of the links and teaching you, like, you got to give me better inputs. But I don't know, like, is there, do you feel like you mentioned this move to conversational? Do you feel like we're at an end to this sort of like, I don't know what the right word would be like, strict, I'm looking for this word or concept directly to appear to something
甚至我是如何与它互动的，我想这些系统在训练我们的同时，也在被我们训练——比如通过你对链接质量的反馈来教导它，让你明白“你得给我更好的输入”。但我不确定，比如，你是否觉得——你刚才提到了这种向对话式的转变，你觉得我们是否正在接近这样一种模式的终点：我不知道用什么词来形容，比如这种严格的、我直接寻找某个特定词语或概念的搜索，转变为某种
that's more akin to how we would ask a question to someone behind the desk at a bookstore or, you know, someone at a university? Is that the sort of like direction that you think we're kind of moving? Yeah, definitely. I think you pretty much nailed it with your analysis, especially of the card catalogs and maybe the bookstores you were looking for books at. I think that's a great example of kind of the general direction in which it's been evolving. I think in some ways, you know, the reason why it's bad is because it's a tough problem. So, you know, when you have really, you know, long user queries
更类似于我们在书店的前台向别人提问，或者在大学里向某人提问的方式？你认为这正是我们正在前进的方向吗？是的，绝对是的。我认为你的分析非常准确，特别是关于卡片目录以及你过去找书的书店的分析。我认为这是它一直在演进的大致方向的一个极好的例子。我认为在某些方面，你知道，它之所以不好，是因为这是一个难题。所以，当你有很长的用户查询，
with ambiguous context and a lot of assumptions, it can definitely be tricky in order to kind of surface the right document or result for you or answer even. But I think that's definitely the direction in which we're heading. And a lot of this has been enabled by a ton of advancements that have happened in natural language processing over the last five this year's five six years um it's actually been tremendous i think there's been like multiple paradigm shifts essentially in terms of you know the way in which we can kind of deal with language uh with machine learning essentially that have kind of opened up new possibilities um so yeah i think and if i were to give kind of deal with language, with machine learning, essentially, that have kind of opened up new
包含模棱两可的上下文和大量的假设时，要为你呈现正确的文档、结果甚至答案，确实会变得很棘手。但我认为这绝对是我们正在前进的方向。这其中很大一部分得益于过去五六年里自然语言处理领域发生的大量进展，这五年六年间的发展实际上是巨大的。我认为在处理语言的方式上，基本上已经发生了多次范式转移——本质上是通过机器学习来处理语言，这为我们开启了新的可能性。所以，是的，我认为如果我要给出——通过机器学习来处理语言，本质上这已经开启了新的
possibilities. So yeah, I think if I were to give kind of a simple example of how we're moving in this direction, there's kind of this one concept in search known as semantic search. So you know, oftentimes, I think what you're referring to, and a lot of classical information retrieval is dealt around keyword search. And keyword search, no doubt is still even important today. But the idea behind keyword search is that when you, no doubt, is still even important today. But the idea behind keyword search is that when you look up something, you basically look for the exact word in a document. And you can obviously do some math, kind of, you know, normalize over the length of the document and other types of things. But now we're actually also, you know, moving into a world in
可能性。所以，是的，我认为如果我要给出一个简单的例子，说明我们是如何朝着这个方向发展的，在搜索领域有一个叫做语义搜索的概念。所以你知道，通常情况下，我认为你所指的以及许多传统的 信息检索都围绕着关键词搜索。毫无疑问，关键词搜索在今天仍然很重要。但关键词搜索背后的理念是，当你查找某样东西时，你基本上是在文档中寻找确切的词语。你显然可以做一些数学运算，比如在文档长度上进行归一化和其他类型的事情。但现在我们实际上也正在进入一个世界，
which semantic search is becoming, you know, more important and better, essentially, where you can basically have a user's query or question and you can do what's called, or basically a look in essentially what we call embed the question in a way in which you can kind of understand the context a bit more and then find similar documents. So even if the keywords don't exactly match up,
语义搜索变得越来越重要，本质上也越来越好。在这里，你基本上可以输入用户的查询或问题，然后你可以进行所谓的“嵌入（embedding）”，或者本质上是以某种方式将问题嵌入，从而让你能够更多地理解上下文，然后找到相似的文档。因此，即使关键词不完全匹配，
but the spirit of the question is similar to kind of the answer, we could still, you know, surface those now. And there's also been subsequent works, you know, dealing with large language models, et cetera, that kind of, you know, even further pushed the possibilities. But yeah, I think to answer your question,
但问题的精神实质与答案相似，我们现在依然可以把它们呈现出来。随后还有一些后续的工作，涉及大语言模型等等，这些工作进一步推动了可能性的边界。但话又说回来，我认为要回答你的问题，
that was a long-winded way of saying yes. No, no, no, it's great. Yeah, so I guess like this keyword versus, I mean, I don't have the right terms for it. So I think that was a long-winded way of saying no no that's great yeah so i i guess like this this keyword versus i mean i don't i don't have the right terms for it so i think that was really good thank you that that helps me put put words to it i guess there are still times where um you can go to duck duck go and sort of like put in you know i want to search the cpp reference documents for like i know the function i'm using i just always forget the order of inputs you know the order of the input parameters or whatever.
我刚刚兜了个大圈子才说“是”。不，不，不，这很好。是的，所以我想，这种关键词与——我的意思是，我没有用对术语。所以我想那是一段长篇大论最后说“不，不，那很好。是的，所以我想，这种关键词与——我的意思是，我——我没有用对术语，所以我觉得那真的很好，谢谢你，这帮我把这些词语表达出来了。我想仍然会有这样的时候，你可以去DuckDuckGo，然后输入，比如“我想搜索C++参考文档，查找某个函数，我知道我正在使用的函数，但我总是忘记输入参数的顺序，或者是输入参数的顺序之类的。”
So like I want, I know exactly what I want. I want this, you know, document this, you know, thing, but it's still, you know, I don't know, first Python or first C++ or maybe tens of thousands of pages. You can't, we don't even print out books when I, you know, we used to have like, you know, language manuals or whatever you'd flip through. But now like you couldn't do that.
所以，就像我想要的那样，我确切地知道我想要什么。我想要这个文档，这个东西，但它依然，我不知道，第一版Python还是第一版C++，或者可能是成千上万页。你做不到，我们甚至不再打印书籍了，就像我以前经历的那样，我们过去常常有语言手册之类的东西可以翻阅。但现在你做不到这一点了。
Like it wouldn't be practical for like the C standard library it'd just be gigantic uh or boost or something um you know and so now like yeah we rely on still maybe that keyword search like i actually do know what i'm looking for very specifically and i just want you to you know sort of find that thing but i i feel like that uh when i'm, maybe that's true. But that's sort of the exception. Often, like I was saying, even difference of not knowing semantic versus keyword. A lot of times you were saying like nearest neighbors earlier, you may not know the term nearest neighbors is like the academic way of describing finding the nearest cell to you by distance for, you know, matching an attribute set. And so you try to go to the search
对于C标准库来说，这根本不切实际，它会变得极其巨大，或者像Boost库之类的东西。你知道，所以现在我们依然依赖于这种关键词搜索，就像我实际上非常具体地知道我在找什么，我只是想让你帮我找到那个东西。但我总觉得，当我——也许这是对的。但这只是一种例外。通常情况下，正如我刚才所说，甚至连不懂语义搜索和关键词搜索的区别也是如此。就像你刚才提到的“最近邻（nearest neighbors）”，你可能并不知道“最近邻”这个词是学术上的说法，用来描述通过距离找到离你最近的单元，以便匹配属性集。所以你尝试去搜索引擎，
engine, and you're just trying to describe the problem, finding the closest thing to me algorithm. And, you know, you're hoping that the search engine can sort of like, deduce that you're looking for, like you said, a document that describes how to do that thing. And from there, that this concept becomes obvious of like nearest neighbor search, and then maybe you can refine or go back. So that, I guess that's the semantics of it, like understanding what you're asking, and then knowing the answer to that question and giving you useful results to that. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I think that's a good way of kind of rephrasing it in a little bit more of a understandable way. But yeah, I think there's a lot of value to be gained by also knowing when to do each. I think in some ways, searches in some ways,
然后你只是试着描述这个问题：“寻找离我最近的东西的算法”。然后，你希望搜索引擎能够推断出你在寻找——就像你刚才说的——一个描述如何做到这一点的文档。从那里开始，“最近邻搜索”这个概念变得显而易见，然后你也许可以进行提炼或回溯。所以，我想这就是它的语义所在，理解你在问什么，然后知道那个问题的答案，并为你提供有用的结果。是的，完全正确。是的，这说得通。是的，我认为这是一种用更容易理解的方式重新表述它的好方法。不过，我认为知道什么时候该用哪种方法也能带来巨大的价值。我认为在某些方面，搜索在某种程度上
it's a very vague problem and it's a very all-encompassing one. So almost a lot of things that we do can be rephrased as search problems. You could think of all of coding as being one giant search problem where you're given a goal and you have to figure out what to do. And I think we're slowly going to kind of keep bridging that gap. And we'll see search kind of expand its scope a little bit into more, you know, what we call do actions instead of just being giving you information, allowing you to do things and eventually even doing things for you. So, you know, one example, you know, might be, and this is something that, and maybe this is kind of going in a little bit of an odd direction, but, you know, typically, you know, in search engines, you are getting content, but I think also now you can kind of, with a lot of advancements, you could think about, you know, making it take action for you.
是一个非常模糊的问题，也是一个包罗万象的问题。所以我们做的很多事情几乎都可以重新表述为搜索问题。你可以把所有的编程看作是一个巨大的搜索问题，在这个问题中，给你一个目标，你必须弄清楚该做什么。我想我们会慢慢地继续弥合这个差距。我们会看到搜索的范围会扩大一点，变得更偏向于我们所说的“执行行动”，而不仅仅是给你提供信息，它允许你做事情，最终甚至替你做事情。所以，你知道，其中一个例子可能是——这可能有点偏离主题，但通常情况下，在搜索引擎中，你获取的是内容，但我也认为现在随着许多进展，你可以考虑让它为你采取行动。
So I'll give you a simple example. There's been a lot of advances in kind of image generation. So I'm sure, I don't know if, I'm sure a lot of the listeners have played with some of these really cool tools out there. So I think one of them would be things like mid-journey, stable diffusion. There's these models that you can give it text, and it'll literally create a really high-fidelity image for you. So when you type in a search engine now, or even in our chatbot, something like generate an image of a cat playing the piano, you'll be able to get that. So this is kind of a little bit of a wonky example. It doesn't really feel like a search problem.
所以我举个简单的例子。在图像生成方面已经有了很多进展。所以，我确信，我不知道，我确信很多听众都玩过市面上一些非常酷的工具。所以我想其中之一就是像Midjourney、Stable Diffusion这样的工具。有这样一些模型，你可以给它一段文字，它就会为你字面意义上地创作出一张高保真的图片。所以现在当你在搜索引擎中输入时，甚至在我们的聊天机器人中，输入诸如“生成一张猫在弹钢琴的图片”之类的内容，你就能得到它。所以这有点像是一个古怪的例子。它其实不怎么像是一个搜索问题。
But in some ways, I think we're going to start seeing a lot more of these types of commands and actions happening within the context of search. And similarly within programming, if you say, you know, I want to, you know, implement, I don't know, a binary tree with this unique case, you know, you may actually end up running into like a, you know, there may be, you know, the search engine might have some type of, you know, code generation module running, and it may just give you your code. That way, you don't have to search through a bunch of documentation, make it yourself. So I think what we're going to see is search is generally going to move a little bit more in this direction of allowing you to do things, as opposed to giving you information that you don't have to read, synthesize yourself, and then do things.
但在某些方面，我认为我们开始看到更多这类命令和行动发生在搜索的语境中。同样在编程领域，如果你说，“我想实现一个带有这种特定情况的二叉树”，你最终可能会遇到这样的情况：搜索引擎可能会运行某种代码生成模块，然后它可能直接把代码给你。这样你就不用去翻阅一堆文档自己去做了。所以我想我们将看到的是，搜索总体上会朝着这个方向发展，更多地允许你去做事情，而不是给你那些你需要自己阅读、自己综合然后才能去干活的信息。
So I think that's going to be another really interesting shift we'll see. Yeah, I guess that's an interesting extension. You said it might be a little bit of a weird direction, but I kind of see it as we were describing like a shift in the way that you provide the information to almost, I don't even want to call it a search engine because like you said, it sort of moves beyond that, but like into the text box, I want to put words or, I mean, to be fair, like I, we've been talking about text box and search engine. I mean, the same is true for any of the smart assistants that you talk to verbally. It almost becomes the same problem, right? It used to be, you had a very formulaic, I need to speak in this precise way.
所以我觉得这将是我们将看到的另一个非常有趣的转变。是的，我想这是一个有趣的延伸。你说这可能是一个有点奇怪的方向，但我看到的是，我们刚才描述了提供信息的方式的转变，几乎——我甚至不想称它为你所说的搜索引擎，因为它已经超越了那个范畴——而是进入了文本框。我想输入文字，或者说，公平地说，我们一直在讨论文本框和搜索引擎。对于你通过语音与之交谈的任何智能助手来说，情况也是一样的。这几乎成了同一个问题，对吧？过去，你的表达非常公式化，我需要用那种精确的方式说话。
And they were all very like singular points of engagement. Like I asked for one thing. And if I ask again, there's no, no context. We were talking about that. Jason was mentioning that with chat GPT. We were sort of going through it and sort of talking about the difference between remembering what you've been, the context versus not remembering. And so I think when we go to the search engine text box or the smart assistants, that not only is there context outside of that text, like that you've
而且它们都是非常单一的互动点。就像我只问一件事。如果我再问一遍，就没有上下文了。我们刚才在谈论这个。杰森在谈论ChatGPT时也提到了这一点。我们当时正在讨论并谈论记住你之前输入的内容的上下文与不记住上下文之间的区别。所以我想，当我们去到搜索引擎文本框或智能助手时，不仅该文本之外还有上下文——比如你之前输入的内容或它对你的了解（个性化就是其中之一），而且你正在描述的——这就像如果我把这视为左侧的输入，但现在你谈论的是输出。它不再是“让我把已经存在的一段信息还给你”——比如Stack Overflow页面、C++文档、Python参数，甚至可能是你的电子邮件，或者无论你拥有的文档库里有什么。你实际上是在说，正如你刚才提到的那样，有时会发生这种情况，比如知识面板或图像生成。在这里，与其说“嘿，我要一张猫的照片，然后让我做一次图像搜索”——其中显然存在着智能，能够知道这是一张图片的画面，有整套图像处理技术来识别这是一张猫的图片以便跟“猫”匹配（因为显然大多数图片本身并没有“猫”这个字在图像里），从而获得这种上下文——不如说，正如你刚才所提到的，更进一步，那就是利用我们现在通过许多这些系统看到的许多进展来生成那个回应。这说得通。所以你认为这是某种——一方面，这挺酷的，但它也可能带来问题，因为正如网络本身在某些方面缺乏权威性一样，我们怎么知道这说得通呢？
previously entered or things that knows about you,ization is one of those but then you're sort of describing the that's like if i think about that as like the left hand inputs but then now you're talking about the outputs it's not let me give you a piece of information that already exists back so a stack overflow page or cpp documentation or python diameters or your email maybe even like whatever it might be that you have in your corpus of documents, you're actually saying now, and you kind of mentioned it happens sometimes like sort of knowledge panels, or like image generation, where rather than saying, hey, I want a picture of cat, and let me do an image search where there's obviously smarts going on for knowing that this is a picture of image, there's the whole image processing stuff that this is an image of a cat to match to cat because obviously most of those
然后，是否存在这样一种情况：我们觉得这些机器学习系统是直接挂钩于文本的，还是说中间存在某种清理系统？这正是我认为今天发生的方式——今天我们输入文本，某种系统坐在中间，像你刚才说的，进行这种嵌入，然后搜索嵌入空间，对吧？并且某种程度上进行这种清理。所以，是否存在这样一种情况：我输入我想要的东西，它就知道如何在下游很好地排队调用各个系统，或者它们只是变成了端到端的系统？我们只是拥有了这些单体式的——我不想称之为通用人工智能，但就是这些知道如何回答问题、生成文本的东西。我想看一集《宋飞正传》，只不过他们在月球上。然后它就像是知道如何去为我创作一个像《宋飞正传》但在月球上的电影。
images don't have the word cat in them uh in the image itself so gaining that context but then as you were mentioning going even one step further which is you know using a lot of the advances we're seeing now with with a lot of these systems to generate that response that makes sense. And so do you think that that's something where I guess one, that's like pretty cool to like, it could be problematic in that like as unauthoritative as the web already is in ways like, how do we sort of know that it makes sense?
是的，这是一个很好的问题。我想答案可能两者兼有。所以我想在某些方面，我们绝对不应该最终放弃权威性的内容。我认为拥有带有引用的内容是非常重要的。所以我想，例如，如果你在查阅信息，有时阅读诸如详细信息和源文档、自己去挖掘答案，而不仅仅是看搜索引擎浓缩后给你的内容，是非常重要的。所以我想这也会引入一种新的偏见形式，这确实会有点问题。因此，我认为我是这样看的：这真的
And then is there like a thing where we feel that those machine learning systems hang off of the text directly or is there some sort of like cleanup system that sits in between which is is sort of how i think about it happening today like today we put text in some sort of system sits in between to sort of like like you said do this embedding and then search the embedding space right and sort of sort of do this cleanup. And so does something exist where I put in what I want and it knows how to queue the systems well downstream, or did they just become end to end? We just have like these monolithic, I don't want to call it general AI, but these things that just know how to answer questions, generate text. I want to watch a Seinfeld episode, except they're on the moon. And it just like knows how to go create like,
取决于具体情况。搜索是一个非常多元化的任务。即使在搜索内部，人们通过搜索想要完成的事情也有许多不同的类别。其中一些事情，我认为生成式的内容是合理的。例如，如果你现在要求搜索引擎写一首诗。我认为在这种情况下，如果它不一定给出引用，或者如果它是在给你提供灵感，或者如果你问一些问题，比如“谁赢得了世界杯”，在这种情况下，如果你能权威地直接说出“阿根廷”，那就是正确答案，把它展示出来是可以的。显然引用也非常重要，但我认为在某些方面，展示文档和真正具有客观依据的材料同样重要，这能让人们确保他们某种程度上与现实保持联系，而不是盲目地全盘接受人工智能告诉他们的任何东西。所以我想这是一个很好的平衡。这也是我们一直在努力寻找的东西：我们如何在用户获取快速内容的渴望与让他们能够自己挖掘事实并获得像引用这样值得信赖的信息的需求之间找到平衡？所以我想这可能是我们正在思考的平衡点，
you know, a movie for me that's like Seinfeld, but on the moon. Yeah, this is a great question. And I think the answer is probably a bit of both. So I think in some ways, you know, you know, we definitely should not end up, you know, moving away from authoritative content. I think having content that has citations is very important. So I think, for example, if you're looking up information, sometimes it's very important to, you know, read like kind of the details and the source documentation, and to dig up answers for yourself, and not just kind of see what a search engine condenses and gives to you. So I think that can also introduce a new form of bias that can really be a little bit problematic. So I think, you know, the way I think about it is, it really
即如何将这两者结合起来。我们对这一点的看法也是，知识库在未来仍然会非常重要。所以，即使我们生活在一个看起来ChatGPT似乎能够回答各种问题的世界里，在某些方面，确保我们拥有这些AI系统可以与之交互的知识库仍然非常重要。我认为这最终将是我们解决这个问题的方式：你向ChatGPT询问某些事情。
depends. I think search is such a diverse task. Even within search, there's so many different categories of types of things people are looking to accomplish from search. Some of those things, I think, make sense for generations. So for example, if you ask, right now you ask a search engine to write me a poem. I think in that case, it's okay if it doesn't necessarily cite, if it's giving you you ideas or if you ask questions like you know when like who won the world cup in that case if you can authoritatively just kind of say Argentina that's that's the correct answer and that's okay to kind of show that there and obviously citations are are very important but I think in some ways it's also important to you know surface documentation
或者在这个例子中，也许我们不用ChatGPT，而是像u.com这样，你向我们询问某些东西，我们会使用大量的人工智能来为你生成答案，但希望这种生成能够得到知识库和权威信息的强力支持，我们会连同引用一起提供给你。这对我来说——至少对u.com来说——是一个北极星指标，即如何弥合这一差距。所以我想你指出了搜索中一个非常重要的问题，我认为这也是当前搜索以及生成式AI领域中最棘手的问题之一：平衡点在哪里？对于哪些用例，纯粹生成且没有引用的内容是可以接受的？什么时候需要引用？
and really ground truth material that allows people to kind of make sure they have, they're in touch with kind of reality in some ways and not just, you know, immediately ingesting anything an AI tells them. So I think that's the great balance. I think that's something we're trying to find as well is how do we balance the need for, you know, the user's desire to get quick content with kind of allowing them to be able to dig into facts themselves and have trustworthy information, like citations. So I think that's kind of maybe a balance we're thinking about
你知道，在什么程度上你需要展示引用？在什么程度上你可以对它们进行调整和释义？这些都是非常棘手的问题，我想我们必须去面对它们。是的，这有点偏离主题。所以我简单地沉浸在这个话题中一下，然后我们就可以回来。但当你刚才谈到引用和权威性时，我不禁想起——这并不是要表现得反乌托邦并说“其实很难说什么是真实的”。所以你可以说：“哦，谁赢得了世界杯？”好吧，即使是这个，我的意思是，我们可以深入探讨，但我觉得在表面层面上，去寻找一个
is how to integrate the two of them together. And the way we think about this is also that I think knowledge bases are still going to be very important in the future. So even if we live in a world where, you know, it seems like ChatGPT is able to answer all sorts of things, in some ways it's still going to be very important to make sure that, you know, we have knowledge bases that these AI systems can interface with. And I think that's ultimately going to be the way in which we solve this is that you'll have, you know, you'll ask ChatGPT something.
大家普遍认为具有权威性的人是相当直接的——哦，我可以去国际足联（FIFA）的网站，FIFA网站被确定为该信息的真相源泉，所以无论他们说什么（我们先忽略他们可能被黑客攻击之类的假设），但是还有其他一些问题非常难以回答，或者可能具有争议性、变得政治化。我不想给出任何例子，免得把谈话的色彩搞得太浓厚。但我认为确实存在某些你问的问题，实际上非常困难——并且不要再扯上另一个让人谈之色变的话题，比如加密货币。但我当时正在阅读关于预言机（oracles）如何在加密货币系统中工作的内容，因为你想做一个博彩市场。
Or in this case, you know, maybe let's not use ChatGPT, but like with u.com even, like you ask us something and we'll use a lot of ai to kind of generate the answer for you and but but hopefully the generation will hopefully be backed very strongly by you know knowledge bases and authoritative information that we'll give to you with citations and that's kind of the north star i think for me at least is and for you.com at least is how to kind of bridge that gap so i think what you you pointed out like a really important i think one of the toughest problems in search right now and in generated i in general is, you know, what is the balance there? For what use cases is it OK to have pure generated content with no citations? When do you need citations?
所以我想押注，你知道，谁赢得了总统大选，或者谁将赢得世界杯。但当然，它们——什么系统会提供答案？当有人说“不，实际上那不是答案”时，你如何解决争议？所以有时问题本身可能是构思不当的，比如它以目前的形式是无法回答的，或者不是无可争议地可以回答的。那么，你如何进行这种声誉的质押，或者在这个例子中是金钱或代币的质押？这只是一种非常有趣的方式，从一个完全去中心化的、我谁也不信任的起点开始，我们如何做到这一点？最终它还是归结为投票，归结于谁愿意将他们的资源、他们的代币押在一边或另一边，
You know, to what degree do you need to surface the citations? To what degree can you adapt them and paraphrase? So these are all really thorny questions that I think we're going to have to come to grips with. Yeah, it's a bit of a side tangent. So I'll, I'll indulge it briefly, and then we can return. But one of the things when you were sort of talking there about citations and authoritative and not to be like, dystopian and say, it's very actually difficult to say what's true. So you can say, Oh, who won the World Cup? Well, even that, I mean, we could we could get into it but like i guess at a surface level it's pretty straightforward to sort of like find someone
并希望他们能够理解普遍的答案会是什么。再次申明，我并不是要卷入加密货币的讨论本身，尽管我很乐
who generally people would agree is authoritative like oh i could go to the fifa website and the fifa website is determined to be the like source of truth for this information and so whatever they say and let's just ignore the fact that they could get hacked or whatever but like there are other questions that are just very difficult to answer or maybe uh contentious or become political i don't i don't want to give any examples to like it'll color the conversation too much but i think there are just certain you know questions that you ask where actually it's very difficult and not to to tag another you know i guess like mean thing to talk about cryptocurrency. But I was reading about sort of how oracles work in cryptocurrency systems where you want to do like a betting market.
大家通常会认同某些具有权威性的东西，比如“哦，我可以去国际足联的网站，而国际足联的网站被认为是这个信息的真实来源，所以不管他们说什么——我们先忽略他们可能会被黑客攻击之类的假设——但还有其他一些问题非常难以回答，或者可能带有争议，或者变得具有政治性”。我不想举任何例子，因为那样会使对话色彩太浓厚，但我觉得确实有某些你提出的问题，实际上非常难以回答。为了顺便抛出另一个关于加密货币的尖锐话题，我当时正在阅读加密货币系统中预言机是如何运作的，比如你想做一个博彩市场。
So I want to bet on, you know, who won the presidential election or who's going to win the World Cup. But of course, they like what system is going to provide the answer. And how do you resolve disputes where someone says, no, actually, that that wasn't the answer. And so sometimes the question itself could be ill posed, like it's not answerable in its current form or not uh undisputedly answerable and so how do you have this like staking of reputation or in this case money or you know coins in order to it's just a very interesting way to sort of start from a very decentralized i trust no one, how do we, and then it just ultimately ends up boiling down to a vote and who's willing to like, put their sort of like resources, their coins behind, you know, one side or the other,
所以我想押注，比如，谁赢得了总统大选，或者谁将赢得世界杯。但当然，什么样的系统会提供答案呢？当有人说“不，实际上那不是答案”时，你该如何解决争议？所以有时问题本身可能表述不清，比如在其当前形式下无法回答，或者无法无可争议地回答。那么，你如何通过这种声誉质押——或者在这种情况下是金钱或代币——来……这只是一种非常有趣的方式，从一个极其去中心化的“我不信任任何人，我们该怎么做”的起点出发，最终归结为一场投票，看谁愿意把他们的资源、他们的代币押在一边或另一边，
and hope that they're, they sort of understand the, what the general answer is going to be. Again, not trying to get into the cryptocurrency discussion per se, although I'm happy to go there. But I think just this, this thing you mentioned that we're going to with these systems of text generation, search engines, like many systems are going to be trying to give answers that some people aren't going to listen to the warnings, and they're just going to take as truth. But even how do they train themselves and what is true? And whatever source you rely on, people can become an attack vector where people attempt to overwhelm that source of truth
并希望他们能理解大体上的答案会是什么。再次说明，我并不是想陷入加密货币本身的讨论，尽管我很高兴深入探讨。但我认为，你提到的这一点正是我们在面对这些文本生成系统、搜索引擎时所遇到的：许多系统会试图给出答案，而有些人不会听取警告，直接将其视为真理。但它们是如何训练自己的？什么是真实的？无论你依赖什么来源，人们都可能成为一个攻击点，大家会试图压倒那个真实来源，
to like say something else, right? So, oh, the FIFA website, right? Like we said, like it could get hacked. You could try to like, you know, say that the FIFA website is somehow biased. We don't need to go in there. The bribery scandals, whatever, right? Like, oh, you can't actually trust them. You need need to trust this other thing and i think it's just very interesting that this
比如去说别的话，对吧？所以，“哦，国际足联的网站”，就像我们说的，“它可能会被黑客攻击”。你可能会试图去说“国际足联的网站在某种程度上是有偏见的”。我们不需要深究贿赂丑闻之类的，对吧？比如“你其实不能相信他们，你需要相信另一个东西”。我觉得非常有趣的是，这个
somewhat subtle question like the hard problem seems to be just how do you give an answer but then when you peel back the onion layer once and say like okay but what is the actual answer uh so even if we all agreed on what the question was are we actually able to agree on the answer so again So again, I know that's a bit of a side tangent. But just when you were sort of saying it leads me to this, like, so exciting to see this progress where you can type in something, and a lot of times it's right or really close. And then you go that one step further, like, oh, wait a minute, hang on, there's like some still like foundational level questions where, you know, it's sort of is that Godel, the incompleteness theorem? Like you can't actually have like fundamental axioms that like describe your
有些微妙的问题——这个难题似乎就在于你如何给出一个答案，但当你剥开洋葱的一层，说“好吧，但实际的答案是什么”时——所以，即使我们都同意问题是什么，我们真的能够就答案达成一致吗？所以，再次说明，我知道这有点跑题了。但正如你所说的那样，这让我觉得：看到这种进展真是太令人兴奋了，你可以输入一些东西，很多时候它是对的或者非常接近正确。然后你再往前迈出一步，“哦，等一下，还有一些非常基础层面的问题”，你知道的，这有点像哥德尔不完备定理？你实际上无法拥有能够描述你的
entire, like some things are sort of like not provable. And this is somewhat dissatisfactory that you can't build an entire, okay. More tangents, but that's just like what tipped me off when you were sort of talking. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, those are, I think you made a lot of good points. And yeah, I think in some ways, again, it's like a balance because we have to make assumptions about the world. You know, we do this every day that could be wrong. I think the same is true of search is that, you know, when we provide an answer, we will have to make assumptions. Like, for example, if you ask who won the World Cup, we have to base that on some type of information, especially, well, I guess, yeah, in order to give an answer.
全部……比如有些事情是无法证明的。这有点令人不满，你无法建立一个完整的……好吧。更多的题外话，但这正是你说话时触发我的想法。对，对。我是说，那些……我觉得你提出了很多很好的观点。是的，我认为在某些方面，这同样是一个平衡问题，因为我们必须对世界做出假设。你知道，我们每天都在这样做，而且可能是错的。我认为搜索也是如此，你知道，当我们提供答案时，我们必须做出假设。比如，如果你问谁赢得了世界杯，我们必须将此建立在某种类型的信息基础之上，尤其是……好吧，我想，为了给出一个答案。
And then the sources we choose, like, for example, you mentioned the FIFA website. In general, we can assume it's quite reputational. There's other websites, news outlets, etc. And I think in some ways, you're right that we do have to make assumptions there. And those assumptions can often be wrong, right? Things can be changing. I think one of the key kind of ideas or principles is also to make sure that information can be cited as much as possible. So for example, the statement, say that FIFA was hacked, the statement, Argentina won the World Cup would then be wrong if it turns out that France actually won. But the statement, according to FIFA.com, that's self contained, and it's still somewhat right. So in some ways, you know, you can at least provide like, like answers that are rooted in independent context, where the user and, or, you know, yeah, I guess the user in this case, would look at that answer. And even if it's wrong, it would be kind of self contained
然后我们选择的来源，比如你提到的国际足联网站。总的来说，我们可以假设它非常有声誉。还有其他网站、新闻媒体等。我认为在某些方面你是对的，我们在那里确实必须做出假设。这些假设往往可能是错误的，对吧？情况一直在变。我认为关键的理念或原则之一，也是要确保信息尽可能多地被引用。因此，举个例子，“国际足联被黑客攻击”这个说法，“阿根廷赢得世界杯”这个说法，如果事实证明其实是法国赢了，那它就是错的。但“根据 FIFA.com 的说法”这个说法是自洽的，它在某种程度上仍然是正确的。所以在某种程度上，你至少可以提供植根于独立上下文的答案，用户或者……是的，我猜在这种情况下用户会查看那个答案，即使它是错的，它在错误性上也是自洽的，
in its wrongness. And all the assumptions would be, you'd be able to investigate them within the answer. And I think that's kind of in general, the importance of citations is being able to kind of dig in and understand. So if you example, if you look up, you know, what is the nutritional value of a banana? Or how much protein is in a banana? And we just spit an answer out at you. And that answer could be, I think in some ways it's contested, right? Like maybe it's not clear exactly how much protein is in a banana. Which study, what, what, what area of the world are you in? Like the bananas are different depending on where they're grown.
并且所有的假设，你都能够在答案中对它们进行调查。我认为这通常就是引用的重要性所在，也就是能够深入挖掘和理解。所以，如果你查一下，比如，香蕉的营养价值是什么？或者香蕉里有多少蛋白质？然后我们直接把一个答案吐给你。那个答案可能是……我认为在某些方面是有争议的，对吧？比如，香蕉里到底有多少蛋白质可能并不完全清楚。你参考了哪项研究？你在世界的哪个地方？因为香蕉因种植地点的不同而有所差异。
So there's all this like nuance, right? So you have to make assumptions. And it seems like kind of one way we get around that is by trying to provide the sources so that if the user wants to dig in more, they can. Oftentimes, people won't want to, they just want a very rough answer. And it's okay. But you know, you don't know that ahead of time. So I think I think that's one kind of, you know, line of thinking that we're going about. But it's tricky. I think in general, it's somewhat of a historically unsolved problem. And it'll continue to be kind of a big issue in the future. Yeah, this sort of escape hatch you mentioned is really interesting.
所以这里面有很多细微差别，对吧？因此你必须做出假设。似乎我们解决这个问题的一个方法是试图提供来源，以便用户如果想深入挖掘，他们可以这样做。通常情况下，人们不想这样做，他们只想要一个非常粗略的答案，这就足够了。但你事先并不知道这一点。所以我想这也是我们正在采取的一种思路。但这很棘手。总的来说，这是一个历史上尚未解决的问题，而且在未来它仍将是一个大问题。是的，你提到的这种“逃生舱”真的很有意思。
And people like to debate this explainable AI, right? That being able to tell. So in your case, you may not know how it got it right? That like being able to tell. So in your case, you may not know how it got it. It may not be able to explain how it got to the answer, maybe not important, but it's giving you the equivalent of what you would have expected before, which is I click on, I click on the link and I go to the FIFA website. And like you said, you sort of get out of it because, Hey, I use this information and I gave it back to you. And I maybe gave it to you in a more palatable form. I wonder if that adds complication.
人们喜欢争论这种“可解释的 AI”，对吧？能够去讲述……所以在你的情况下，你可能不知道它是怎么做到的，对吧？能够去讲述……所以在你的情况下，你可能不知道它是怎么做到的。它可能无法解释它是如何得出答案的，这或许并不重要，但它为你提供了你之前所期望的等价物，那就是我点击链接，然后访问国际足联的网站。就像你说的，你摆脱了困境，因为：“嘿，我使用了这些信息，然后把它还给你，而且我可能以一种更容易接受的形式交给你。”我想知道这是否会增加复杂性。
And then like, but you mentioned sort of moving beyond, which is like, oh, I want to generate me the nearest neighbor's code with a limit of, you know, 50 meters with the data set. I mean, I could just go on and describe a problem and we could get generation that may touch on, you know, a hundred different, you know, GitHub repositories or whatever. Right. And so this sort of explanation there becomes a bit tricky. You can give your sources, I used all of these inputs, here's a list of 100. But if I go to any one of the 100, I'm not really able to fact check. In the code example,
然后，你提到超越这一点，比如“我想为我生成最近邻的代码，在数据集的限制下，距离为 50 米”。我的意思是，我可以继续描述一个问题，然后我们得到的生成代码可能会触及上百个不同的 GitHub 仓库，诸如此类。对吧？所以这里的解释就变得有点棘手了。你可以给出你的来源：“我使用了所有这些输入，这里是一个包含 100 个来源的列表。”但如果我访问这 100 个来源中的任何一个，我实际上并不能核实事实。在代码的例子中，
it's a little easier because one, hopefully you write unit tests or you can compile the code and make sure it works, which isn't always true out of the systems today. But like, you know, you can kind of go through that. But the same topic sort of appears, right? Which is like, you just mentioned, like, maybe a poem is subjective, so it's a little harder. But when you sort of touch across many things, does that end up becoming, I don't want to say like a limitation, like forcing the system to be required to sort of cite its sources? Does that, it adds an extra step. Does it end up becoming tricky or an issue itself? Like how do you even rank those
这稍微容易一些，因为第一，希望你编写了单元测试，或者你可以编译代码并确保它能运行——虽然这在当今的系统中并不总是成立。但你可以过一遍这个过程。然而同样的主题还是会出现，对吧？也就是你刚才提到的，可能一首诗是主观的，所以会更难一点。但当你跨越许多事物时，这最终会变成——我不想说是一个局限性，比如强迫系统必须引用其来源——这会增加一个额外的步骤吗？它最终会变得棘手或成为一个问题本身吗？你甚至如何对这些来源进行排名？
sources? How do you, like what order do they appear in? What's the correct or, you know, best order becomes like yet more things that the system has to do? Yeah, yeah. I mean, I think you're right that I think it is strictly and somewhat, it's a harder problem to provide a generation with citations and to provide a generation that's somewhat ungrounded. So I think you're right that it is somewhat, it's a harder problem. But I think it's a problem worth solving. And it's something that I think we're interested in kind of going deep and trying to go dig into. I think the other thing is, you know, I don't think all, I think it's important to be able to understand the intent of the query. I mean, I know when to kind of use which system. So I think, again, I think when it comes to search, these discussions can be kind of complicated because of the fact that when we talk about search, search is not really one, you know, single constrained task. It's really a set of so many different types of tasks,
你怎么……比如它们以什么顺序出现？正确或最好的顺序是什么，这变成了系统必须做的又一堆事情？对，对。我是说，我觉得你是对的，带引用的生成以及某种无依据的生成相比，确实是一个更难的问题。所以我觉得你是对的，它确实更难。但我觉得这是一个值得解决的问题，也是我们有兴趣深入探讨的事情。我认为另一件事是，我认为理解查询的意图非常重要。我的意思是，知道何时使用哪个系统。所以我觉得，再次回到搜索上，由于这样一个事实：当我们谈论搜索时，搜索其实并不是一个单一的、受限的任务，它实际上是一组如此之多不同类型的任务，
some of which are frivolous, some of which are extremely important, some of which are even borderline, like life or death situations. And I think all of that is compassed within search. So I think we basically need to be very good at deciding when to engage with one technique versus the other. And I think the other important piece is around user expectations. So I think when it comes to
其中有些是无聊的，有些是极其重要的，有些甚至处于边缘状态，比如生死攸关的情况。我认为所有这些都包含在搜索的范畴之内。所以我觉得我们基本上需要非常擅长决定何时采用哪种技术。另一个重要部分是围绕用户的期望。所以我觉得当涉及到
search, I think it's important that users have the right expectations when they use the product. So I think like if you're in a life or death situation, I would not suggest that, you know, you ask ChatGPT what to do. Definitely good advice. Yes. I don't think open AI would suggest that either. So I think, you know, in some ways, it's really important, no matter how good a product is to always have the right expectations with it. Like if you're feeling sick, or you have some issue with health, I mean, you should probably still see a doctor. Obviously, you know, there's amazing tools now and then search can be very helpful for it. But at the end of the day,
搜索，我认为当用户使用该产品时，有正确的期望是很重要的。所以我认为，如果你处于生死关头，我不建议你让ChatGPT告诉你该怎么做。绝对是个好建议。是的。我想OpenAI也不会建议这样做。所以我认为，在某些方面，无论一个产品有多好，始终对它保持正确的期望真的非常重要。比如如果你感觉身体不适，或者有健康方面的问题，我的意思是，你可能还是应该去看医生。显然，现在有一些很棒的工具，而且搜索在这方面也非常有用。但归根结底，
having the user expectation should be that, you know, you should probably trust your medical professionals. Maybe one day it'll be true that, you know, we'll be so good at doing certain types of things with search that that won't be possible or won't be as necessary, but at least right now
用户的期望应该是，你可能还是应该相信你的医疗专业人员。也许有一天，我们在用搜索做某些类型的事情时会变得如此出色，以至于那将是不可能的或者不再那么必要，但至少现在
and far into the foreseeable future, I mean, it's the case that we should trust, you know, healthcare professionals. So I think in some ways, like the expectations are also important. So, you know, people should know how to use search. I think that's always been the case for search, right? Like we don't, we use Google for very specific things. Like if you ask Google, should I accept this job or not? We know that what to do. So it's important to kind of have the right expectations and using a product. And it's also the, the creator
以及在可预见的未来，我的意思是，我们确实应该信任医疗保健专业人员。所以我觉得在某些方面，期望也很重要。所以，人们应该知道如何使用搜索。我认为搜索一直都是这样，对吧？就像我们不会用Google来做非常具体的事情一样。如果你问Google，我该不该接受这份工作？我们知道该怎么做。所以在产品的使用中，对各种事情抱有正确的期望是很重要的。而且这也是产品的创造者
of the products that are, it's also the creator of the products. It's their responsibility to make sure that the expectations are communicated appropriately so people use it the right way. I think with AI, we're going to see this happen a lot more where there's going to be a mismatch between kind of expectations and what the product can deliver. And that'll lead to some issues.
产品的创造者也负有责任。确保正确地传达期望，以便人们以正确的方式使用它。我认为随着人工智能的发展，我们将看到这种情况发生得更多，期望与产品能够交付的成果之间会出现脱节。这将导致一些问题。
So I think we're trying to think hard about, you know, making sure that we can promote responsible usage of whatever we build. So I just wanted to jump in and ask a question about the structured data and and how to kind of incorporate that into something like chat gbt and we've seen a lot of articles talking about like oh i asked chat gbt what seven plus three is and it said it was 13 you know and so it's it doesn't like uh it's its own self-contained neural network which which can't rely on things from the outside so it can't go and ask wolfram alpha for an answer right and so i'm wondering like how do you where do you see that going like can you like how could we train something which knows, like to start writing
所以我认为我们正在努力思考，确保我们能够推广我们所构建的任何内容的负责任使用。所以我只是想插话问一个关于结构化数据的问题，以及如何将其融入像ChatGPT这样的产品中。我们看到很多文章都在讨论，哦，我问ChatGPT“7加3等于几”，它说是13，你知道的，所以它不喜欢，呃，它是一个独立的神经网络，无法依赖外界的事物，所以它不能去问Wolfram Alpha获取答案，对吧？所以我很好奇，你觉得这会朝哪个方向发展？比如我们如何训练一个程序，让它开始编写
text, and then at some point to stop and say, I need to make a SQL query, and then put the result of a SQL query there and then keep writing text? Like, how is that? Where do you how do you think it's going to unfold? Yeah, that's a great question. And I think in some ways, it depends on what the purpose is. So the purpose of kind of the model and the user expectations around it will determine to what degree you need to do that. So I think, you know, in some cases, I think in some ways like search can be kind of a, it's a hard problem. In some ways it's definitionally impossible to be perfect at because there's so much ambiguity in user requests as well. And you never really know somebody's true intent when they're asking a question,
文本，然后在某个时刻停下来，说“我需要做一个SQL查询”，然后把SQL查询的结果放进去，接着继续写文本？这会是怎样的？你觉得它会如何发展？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我觉得在某种程度上，这取决于它的目的是什么。因此，模型的目的以及用户对其的期望将决定你需要做到什么程度。所以我觉得，在某些情况下，在某些方面，搜索可能是一个难题。从某种程度上说，由于用户请求中存在大量歧义，要求它做到完美在定义上是不可能的。当你提出问题时，你永远无法真正知道某人的真实意图，
but you can always try to approximate it. But I think basically going to your question around, like, I guess, if you rephrase it, I guess you were basically asking what again? Oh, yeah. I was wondering how, like, right now, ChatGPT, you know, it just keeps calling the neural network. Yeah, it gets like, okay, the dog jumped over the fence. I'm wondering if it could get to a point where it could say, you know, yeah, the net worth of Shaquille O'Neal is, And then instead of just calling the neural network again, it knows at this point that it needs to like make a SQL query to like net worth database or something like that.
但你总是可以尝试去接近它。但我觉得基本上回到你刚才的问题，如果你重新表述一下，我猜你刚才基本上又问了什么？哦，是的。我在想，就像现在这样，ChatGPT，你知道的，它只是不断调用神经网络。是的，它会得到类似“小狗跳过了篱笆”这样的结果。我在想它是否能达到这样一个程度，比如它可以说：“沙奎尔·奥尼尔的身价是，然后它不是再次调用神经网络，而是知道此时它需要向身价数据库之类的东西发出一个SQL查询。”
Yeah, yeah. Okay, sorry. I remember I got lost in a tangent. So thank you for bringing me back. No, it happens to all three of us. But basically, I think what you're talking about is something that maybe I had mentioned a little bit earlier about knowledge bases being important. So I think it's okay. So it depends on what ChatGPT's goal
是的，是的。好的，抱歉。我记得我刚才扯远了。所以谢谢你把我拉回来。不，我们三个人都会这样。但基本上，我觉得你刚才谈论的内容，可能就是我之前稍微提到过的“知识库很重要”这一点。所以我觉得没问题。这取决于ChatGPT的目标
is. So in some cases, you know, they have an API that they allow other people to use, and they don't necessarily need to solve that problem. Maybe they will. But it does seem like it's the responsibility of people building the products to know when to use a tool and how to use it. But I think the way, you know way I think about it at least is that it's going to be really important to know when to plug in knowledge bases. So if you're looking up what is the stock price of Microsoft, it's very unlikely that a neural network will be able to answer that question properly. Maybe one day if it has a live feed plugged in or whatever. But even then you need some component. There needs to be something that's kind of monitoring the real world and is
是什么。所以在某些情况下，他们有一个API供其他人使用，他们不一定非要解决那个问题。也许他们会。但构建产品的人似乎有责任知道何时以及如何使用工具。不过我认为，至少在我看来，知道何时接入知识库将是非常重要的。如果你在查微软的股价是多少，神经网络很可能无法正确回答这个问题。也许有一天它接入了实时数据源或者别的什么。但即便如此，你仍然需要某个组件。需要有某种东西在监控现实世界，并且
aware of events that are happening. So I think it's kind of clear when you look at it that way, that knowledge bases are important and we need some way of kind of having AI interfacing with them. And that's kind of maybe what I was talking about earlier when, you know, I think that, you know, the way that we're going to go about this, and I think that maybe the optimal way is to really think about how to combine
了解正在发生的事件。所以当你从这个角度看时，就很清楚了，知识库非常重要，我们需要某种方式让AI与它们进行交互。这可能就是我之前谈到的，我认为我们将要采用的方法，而且我认为最佳的方法是认真思考如何将
some of these advances in AI with a lot of the knowledge that we've collected, crawled, and kind of indexed as a search engine. So I think we'll need a mix of both and we'll need to know essentially when to draw on one versus the other and how to basically combine a lot of the advances in generative AI with a lot of the advances in traditional
人工智能的一些进展与我们作为搜索引擎收集、抓取并索引的大量知识结合起来。所以我想我们需要两者的结合，并且基本上需要知道什么时候利用其中一个，什么时候利用另一个，以及如何将生成式AI的许多进展与传统
and kind of, I guess, neural information retrieval. So I think it's a hard problem. But yeah, I think you're right that I think that it will be important to connect to valid authoritative sources of information so people can trust the content that we provide. Yeah, that makes sense. I think the hardest part is on the, on the, um, um, like data curation side, you know, if you're going to, for example, scrape Wikipedia, well, Wikipedia, you know, humans went in and wrote like Shaquille O'Neal's net worth is X, but they, they didn't make X like,
以及某种程度上我猜的神经信息检索的许多进展结合起来。所以这是一个难题。但是是的，我觉得你说得对，连接到有效且权威的信息源将是很重要的，这样人们才能信任我们提供的内容。是的，这说得通。我觉得最难的部分在数据整理这块，你知道的，如果你打算抓取维基百科，嗯，维基百科，你知道的，人类进去写了“沙奎尔·奥尼尔的身价是X”，但他们并没有把X弄成某种
uh, some kind of token that is updated. It's just someone maybe looked it up on the internet, found it, and then hard-coded whatever the dollar amount is. And so we have to somehow reverse that process. We have to say, okay, this sentence from Wikipedia or whatever our input corpus is says, Shaquille's net worth is I don't know like 100 million or something and we have to be able to say okay that number actually
可以更新的Token。而只是某个人可能在互联网上查了一下，找到了它，然后硬编码了具体的金额。所以我们必须以某种方式逆转这个过程。我们必须说，好的，来自维基百科或我们的任何输入语料库的这句话说，沙奎尔的身价我不知道大概是1亿美元左右，我们必须能够说，好的，这个数字实际上
like there's a way I could get the latest version of that number like that number actually represents some kind of structure yeah I know that OpenAI spends a ton of time and energy on you know curating the data set and And I think that's going to be even more important going forward. Yeah, I agree. We also think a lot about curating data sets and having really good data to kind of build AI on and eventually, I guess, conversational search and search for. And I think the way we think about this at least is we have these ideas of u.com apps within our search engine. And, you know, a lot of those apps are, you know, ones that we've built in partnerships with other companies. We have, for example, a Stack Overflow app that, you know, provides kind of trusted programming content
有一种方法可以让我获取该数字的最新版本，这个数字实际上代表了某种结构。是的，我知道OpenAI在整理数据集方面花费了大量的精力和时间，我认为未来这会变得更加重要。是的，我同意。我们也非常注重整理数据集，拥有非常好的数据来构建AI，并最终构建对话式搜索和搜索功能。至少在我们看来，我们在搜索引擎中内置了u.com应用。而且，你知道的，其中许多应用是我们与其他公司合作构建的。例如，我们有一个Stack Overflow应用，它提供受信任的编程内容，
that you can use to kind of supplement kind of generated code content. But I think in general, we also have this idea of like an open platform where, you know, we can have other people plug in and build apps with their own data. And eventually that will be used in conversational search as well. So I think when it comes to data curation, it's important. And I also think it's important that it's opened up. So there's not just one search engine really, you know, controlling all of kind of the data that's being curated,
你可以用它来补充生成的代码内容。但我认为总的来说，我们也有一个开放平台的理念，在那里我们可以让其他人接入并使用他们自己的数据构建应用。最终这也将用于对话式搜索。所以当谈到数据整理时，这很重要。而且我认为保持开放也很重要。这样就不会只有一个搜索引擎真正控制着所有正在整理的数据，
but it's really kind of an open community in some ways that is, you know, providing data and, you know, updating the quality and users can kind of, you know, basically prioritize which sources of data that, you know, they like and they think is trustworthy. So I think that maybe went a little bit further than what you were suggesting, but I think it's a great point about data creation. No, it makes sense. That was a fantastic answer. So we're getting a little close to the end of time. So what I was going to just give us, we referenced this conversational search a couple of times. So I just wanted to give an opportunity
而是在某种程度上它是一个开放的社区，在提供数据、提升质量，并且用户可以优先选择他们喜欢且认为是值得信赖的数据源。所以这可能比你刚才建议的要稍微深入了一点，但我觉得这是关于数据整理的一个绝佳观点。不，这说得很对。那是一个非常棒的回答。所以我们的时间快到了。因此我想做的就是，我们之前提到了好几次这种对话式搜索。所以我只想在结束之前给大家一个讨论这个的机会。但如果我按照我认为它们字面意思来理解，对话式搜索，即你进行的是更多意义上的对话，而不是我们之前那种传统的提出搜索查询的方式。然后当你提到“对话”时，我总是认为它是双向的。也就是，我问一个问题，我得到一些答案，然后也许我给出改进、反馈或额外的上下文，然后得到正确的，你知道的，它变成了一个双向对话。我是不是理解在我们要讨论的方向上？是的。好极了。
to talk about that before we sort of wrap up. But if I sort of take the words for what I assume that they mean, conversational search, where you're having more of a conversation rather than the traditional posing of search queries we sort of worked through. And then when you say conversational, I always think about it as two ways. So it's like, I'm asking a question, I'm getting some answer, and then maybe I'm giving refinements or feedback or additional context and getting right, you know, it becomes a two way dial. Am I am I in the right in the right vicinity of what we're talking about? Yeah. All right.
太棒了。对于这一点，我的意思是，在某种程度上，我可以看到有时想这样做，有时又不想。但我想如果我开始思考其中的难题，然后，你知道的，也许你可以提出其他难题，或者告诉我我的难题其实并没有那么难。如果你进行这种持续的对话，有时我不会说那是我妻子，但绝对是我妻子。当我说话时，你知道的，进行了一些对话，然后话题切换了，而你并没有意识到话题已经切换了。对吧？所以即使对于——我不会说完全健全的成年人，但对于人类来说，
Awesome. And so for that, I mean, in some ways, I could see wanting to do that on some days and sometimes not. But I guess like if I start thinking about hard problems there and then, you know, maybe you can, you know, follow up with other hard problems or tell me that mine aren't really that hard. If you sort of have this ongoing conversation, sometimes I won't say that it's my wife, but definitely my wife. When I say, you know, have some conversation, she's and then the topic switches and you're not aware the topic has switched. Right. And so this even for I won't say full functioning adults, but like for humans,
泛泛地说，两个人类在对话，话题会发生切换，而跟上话题的切换其实是一个挑战，对吧？甚至不管你有没有在注意，不管别人怎么说，你肯定在听，你肯定在注意。而上下文切换、话题切换的微妙之处是很难辨别的。是的，这绝对是我们正在深入思考并试图改进的地方。但你说得对，当我们考虑对话式搜索时，对话式搜索和普通搜索的主要区别之一在于，对于普通搜索，你基本上每次都在输入一个新的查询。而且你是从零开始的。你无法真正利用你之前做过的上下文，你必须确保无论
I guess, to say generically that, you know, two humans conversing, the topic can switch and keeping up with the topic switches is actually a challenge, right? Not even that you're paying attention, despite whatever someone might say, like you're definitely listening, you're definitely paying attention. And the subtleness of a context switch, a topic switch, can be very difficult to discern. Yeah, I think this is definitely something we're thinking a lot about and trying to improve. But you're right, when we think about conversational search, one of the main differences between conversational search and normal search is that with normal search, you're typing in a new query essentially every time. And you're starting from scratch. You can't really leverage context that you have done previously and you have to basically make sure that whatever
你输入的内容都是自包含的，并且包含了你在过程中学到的所有假设。所以你知道，这通常——我猜对于这种类型的工作有不同的技术术语，但我猜其中之一就是查询重写，也就是你基本上如何编写查询？这就是我们一直在做搜索时所做的事情，我们重写查询是为了包含更多上下文、包含更少上下文，以便获得我们想要的结果。
you're typing in is self-contained and contains all the assumptions that you know you've learned along the way um so you know this is kind of often i guess there's different like you know there's technical words for kind of this this type of work but um i guess one of which is query rewriting is how do you essentially write the query? And this is what we do all the time when we're doing search, we're rewriting our queries in order to include more context, to include less context, in order to get the results we want.
而在对话式搜索中，你基本上是在进行一次聊天，然后进行另一次聊天，并且你某种程度上期望前一次聊天的上下文根据某些假设适用或不适用。所以，例如，如果你查微软的股价是多少，然后你查它的市盈率，你会假设你希望前一次聊天的上下文是相关的。但现在假设你突然说，谁赢了——我不知道——2008年的总统大选。你其实并不需要应用之前的上下文，而且你也不会期望它与微软或任何东西有关。而聊天机器人和对话式搜索应该能够为你处理好这一点。我认为这是一个北极星目标。确实有些情况下上下文变得非常含糊。而且很难分清你是在开始一个新话题，还是在引用你可能在两三个之前的聊天中讨论过的事情，
With conversational search, you're essentially doing a chat and then you're doing another chat and you kind of expect the previous chat's context to apply or not apply, according to some assumptions. So, for example, if you look up what is the stock price of Microsoft and then you look up what is its price earning ratio, you're going to assume that you want the context from the previous chat to be relevant. But now let's say you suddenly say, who won the presidential election in, I don't know, 2008. You don't really need the context to apply and you wouldn't expect it to be related to Microsoft or anything. And the chat bot and conversational search should be able to handle that for you. I think it's a North Star goal. There's definitely cases where the context becomes really ambiguous. And it's ambiguous whether or not you're starting something new, or you're referring to kind of
这对人类来说都是个挑战，所以对任何对话智能体来说肯定也很困难，但这是我们正在研究的一个活跃领域，即如何深入思考……你知道的，如何非常擅长……你知道的，对话流。是的，我觉得——想想你的例子——我想你刚才说的是2008年，谁当选了总统，而99.9%说出这些词的人都想知道总统大选，但你刚才谈到的关于微软的前置条件可能会让它变得含糊，如果微软在那一年也举行了股东总统选举的话，对吧？所以我认为他们没有——但假设他们举行了，对吧？——这个词虽然用得很尴尬，但确实可以适用，现在你被迫一方面要确保聊天程序理解存在两种潜在的可能性，然后又如何以一种不会显得……不会显得前后矛盾的方式将其传达给用户，就好像“我不太确定你在谈论哪一个”，因为那样就太显而易见了，对吧？他们知道自己指的是哪一个，但现在突然之间你陷入了两难境地，要么说一句风马牛不相及的话，比如“哦，你知道的，某某赢得了美国总统大选”，
things that you've talked about maybe even two or three previous chats ago and this is even chart for humans so it's definitely going to be hard for any conversational agent but this is kind of an active area of research that we're working on is how to think a lot about um you know being very good at um you know the conversational flow yeah i feel like so thinking to your example like i think you said 2008 like who who was elected president and 99.9 of people who say that those words want to know the like presidential election but the prior that you were just talking about microsoft could make it ambiguous if microsoft also held a shareholder election for president in that year right and so i i don't i don't think they did like let's just
而他们会觉得“我刚才说的是微软啊”，这就非常……是的，就像你说的，“假设”这个词在这里很关键，里面有很多你未必明确表达出来的假设，所以怎么可能有人或任何系统能猜到呢？是的，这似乎是一个非常困难的问题。是的，是的。
say they did right like the term could apply although awkwardly and now you're forced with one like making sure that the chat understands there's two potential things and then how do you communicate that to the user in a like not uh incongruous way that like i i'm not sure which of the things you're talking because then it's super obvious right they know which one they intended but now all of a sudden you're stuck with a dilemma of either saying a non sequitur like oh well you know so and so won the US presidential election you know
不，我想你说的对。是的，说得好。确实需要做出很多假设。而且我认为我们也必须让这些假设变得清晰。因此，如果我们给你的答案是关于总统大选的，那么答案中应该包含一些暗示我们正在谈论总统大选的上下文。哦，那更棒了。你直接拿不到名字。
and they're like well I was talking about Microsoft like it's a super like yeah like you said assumption is the word there there's a lot of assumption that you didn't necessarily put down and so how could anyone or any system have known it? Yeah, it seems like a very difficult problem. Yeah, yeah.
等一下，我不知道他是微软的总裁。好吧，太棒了。好吧，我的意思是，这是一次相当精彩的旋风式旅行，涉及了各种不同的主题，但我确实学到了一些东西，所以你知道的，我度过了一段非常非常愉快的时光。我们总是喜欢在最后给人们一点时间来谈谈他们工作的公司、那里的文化、你们是否在招人。我可以一个接一个地抛出问题，你可以随心所欲地回答，但让我们先从……你知道的，你提到了好几次u.com，你在那儿已经工作好几年了，在那儿工作感觉怎么样？你知道的，你会推荐其他人加入吗？也许这是个诱导性问题，但……跟我们讲讲那里的文化吧。好的，没问题。
No, I think you made it. Yeah, well put. There's definitely assumptions that need to be made. And I think we have to make those assumptions clear as well. So if we're giving you the answer for the presidential election, there should be kind of some context in the answer that points that we're talking about the presidential election. Oh, that's even better. You just don't get the name.
所以，是的，我的意思是，我觉得在u.com工作绝对是——我觉得最好的形容词就是“一场冒险”。而且我认为我们仍然在不断发展，并试图弄清楚如何在技术不断变化、用户需求每时每刻都在改变的情况下，最好地满足这些需求。我觉得这是一个令人兴奋的领域，搜索、对话式搜索等等。所以本质上，我们非常专注于这些类型的问题。
Yeah. Wait, I didn't know he was president of microsoft so well awesome all right so i mean that was a pretty like whirlwind tour through a variety of different topics but i definitely learned some stuff so you know i had a super super good time we always like to give people a little bit of opportunity at the end to talk about you know sort of the company they work for sort of the culture there are you hiring um i can tee them up one by one you can just sort of go whatever you want but like let's start off like you know you mentioned you.com a few times you've been there for a few years now like how is it like working there you know would you recommend other people to join maybe that's a tf but like uh tell us a little bit about the the and the culture. Yeah, definitely.
如果你觉得它们很有趣，欢迎随时联系我们。我觉得我们的文化大概可以被描述为既注重协作又发展迅速。所以我们的确是以初创公司的节奏在工作。因此我们非常专注于快速迭代、从用户那里快速学习，并且真正地构建一些东西。所以我觉得这或许是除了协作之外的一点。
So, yeah, I mean, I think working at u.com has definitely been, I think the best word to describe it is like an adventure. And I think we're, you know, still evolving and trying to figure out how to, you know, technology is changing, user needs are changing all the time, and how do we best meet those needs. And I think it's kind of an exciting space, search, conversational search, et cetera. So essentially, we're focused very deeply on these types of questions.
重点。是的，我的意思是，如果你想加入或联系我们，你绝对可以通过这个邮箱联系我：sahil@u.com，也就是s-a-h-i-l@u.com。如果我们不想聊搜索话题，你也可以随时给我发消息，我非常乐意聊任何事情。我们说“聊天”说得太多了，人们都要搞不懂你到底是什么意思了。
If you find them interesting, definitely reach out. I think our culture could probably be described as one that is collaborative, but also fast moving. So we definitely work at kind of the face of a startup. So we're very much focused on iterating fast, learning fast from our users and, you know, really, you know, building something. So I think that's kind of maybe one along with kind of collaboration. points yeah i mean if you're looking to to join or reach out you can definitely reach out to me at i guess sahil at u.com so s-a-h-i-l at u.com we'll have that if you didn't want to chat about search topics you can also feel free to message me i'm more than you know happy to chat about anything uh we've said chat too many times people are going to be confused what you mean
你可以给出更多……不，我开玩笑的。所以，是的，我的意思是，你们有实体办公地点吗？还是你们主要是在线远程办公？你们都在哪儿？是的，我们是远程办公的，我们是完全远程的，从一开始就是这样。太棒了。你们公司有人搬到什么非常异国情调的地方去了吗？我们最近刚有一个人搬去了夏威夷。哦，真的吗？我不知道，我觉得没有谁一定搬到了什么非常异国情调的地方，虽然我们的确有一些员工在不同地方，其中一些甚至在国外。好的。好吧。是的，这很诱人。我的意思是，你现在就可以去夏威夷。我以前从没真正想过这件事，直到有人说“我现在在夏威夷”，我才觉得“哦，好吧，这挺有意思的”。是的，我的意思是，现在这可能意味着我在度假兼工作，或者我已经住在这里了。但确实如此。是的，绝对的。我想对于异地办公，确实有一种诱惑。我认为很多公司——虽然不想过多纠缠这个，但我认为在大多数公司，至少对这一点有更多的灵活性或开放性，哪怕只是兼职。我真的认为这是人们应该利用并寻找新方法的机会，尽管这会有点困难，对吧？比如，如果我和家人去度假，他们通常习惯了我全程陪伴他们并且完全在度假。现在你多了一个选择，比如你可以去其他地方待上两个星期，去参观游览，让他们也见识一下，但你可能有一部分时间还在工作。我认为大家彼此之间需要进行一些有趣的权衡。但我绝对认为这将是一个机会，至少对我来说，我希望能好好利用它。我想很多人也会这样，即使你们的文化是完全远程的，也要确保你不仅仅是整天
you get to give more no i'm just kidding uh so yeah i mean are you guys you guys have like uh physical locations are you doing most of virtual where are you guys at yeah so we're remote so we're fully remote um yeah since the start nice did anyone at your company move somewhere really exotic we recently just had someone move to hawaii oh really um i don't know i don't think anybody has necessarily moved anywhere exotic, although we do have employees like, you know, different places. Some of them, you know, outside of the country as well. Okay. All right. Yeah. It's, it's tempting. I mean, you could just go to Hawaii now. It's never didn't really think about it until someone said, I'm in Hawaii now. I said, Oh, yeah, okay, that's interesting. Yeah, I mean, now it could be I'm on vacation slash working or like,
都远程呆在家里，而是要抓住机会去其他地方远程办公。所以，是的，我觉得这挺棒的。关于u.com，你还有什么想推介的吗，Sahil？所以我假设实习生、全职员工，还有什么你想鼓励大家去了解的吗？当然是去看看我们的网站。你去过就知道，你可以试用我们今天谈论的一些功能。它们已经上线网站了。
I live here now. But yes. Yeah, definitely. There is a temptation, I think, for being displaced. I think a lot of companies, you know, to dwell on that, but I got, you know, in most companies, there's at least more flexibility or openness to that, even if it's only part time. And I really think that that's something that people should use and find new ways, it'll be a little difficult, right? Like, if I go on vacation with my family, they're normally used to me being present with them and on vacation the whole time. Now you have an option, like you could take, you know, two weeks somewhere else, you know, and visit and, you know, have them exposed, but you might be working part of the time. I think there's some interesting sort of like calibration
是的，是的。不，我基本上会建议，如果有实习生感兴趣，或者全职工程师、设计师、市场人员，真的欢迎任何人来联系我们。而且我认为这里绝对有很多人的用武之地，特别是那些对让对话式搜索和整个搜索变得更好感兴趣的人。我觉得另一个，是的，我想另一个方面绝对是去看看u.com，看看UCHAT，这是我们的对话式搜索。此外，如果你有兴趣成为社区的一部分，你也可以加入我们的社区。
for everyone to do to each other. But I definitely think that's going to be an opportunity, at least for me, like I hope to be able to leverage. And I think a lot of folks will as well, like being able to, even if your culture is fully remote, making sure you're not just remote
因此，如果你滚动到u.com的底部，有一个“加入社区”按钮。你点击它，我们有一个由不同用户组成的Slack群组。我想我们称他们为测试用户，但在这一点上，我想他们是各种各样的用户。而且非常欢迎你做出贡献，分享你的想法、意见，是的，成为社区的一员。
in your house all the time, like taking opportunities to be remote in other places. So yeah, I think that's pretty awesome. Yeah. Anything else about you.com you want to, you want to sort of pitch, Sahil? So I assume interns, full-time, anything else that you want to kind of like encourage people to check out? Check out the website, of course. You know, I went, you can just go, you can try some of these things we were talking about today. They're already up there on the website.
为对话提供更多训练数据。不，不，不。这不是关于这个的。是的，抱歉，不是的。这跟那没关系。是的，抱歉，抱歉。我不该那样说。当然。那是u.com，免得有人把字母U给打错了。
Yeah, yeah. No, I would basically suggest, you know, if, you know, yeah, definitely interns are interested or full-time engineers, designers, marketers, really anybody is welcome to kind of reach out. And I think there's definitely a place for a lot of people here, especially people who are interested in, you know, making conversational search and search in general even better. And I think the other, yeah, I guess the other aspect would be to definitely check out u.com, check out UChat, which is our conversational search. And also if you're interested in kind of being part of the community, you can also join the community.
You.com。是的，去看看吧。好的，非常感谢大家来到节目中。这是一段美好的时光。我真的很享受这次谈话。也感谢所有一直陪伴我们又一期节目的听众。我们下期再见。
So if you go scroll to the bottom at u.com, there's a join community button. You can click that and we have a Slack group of kind of different users. I guess we call them beta users, but at this point they're, I guess, all sorts of users. And you're definitely welcome to kind of contribute, share your thoughts, ideas, and yeah, be part of the community.
Eric Barn Dollar的音乐。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音和改编，但你必须对Patrick和我进行署名，并以相同方式进行共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Provide more training data for conversations. No, no, no. This is not about that. Yeah, sorry, no. This is not about that. Yeah, sorry, sorry. I shouldn't say that. Definitely. And that's you.com, just so no one types the letter U.
为对话提供更多训练数据。不，不，不。这不是关于那个的。对，抱歉，不。这不是关于那个的。对，抱歉，抱歉。我不该那样说。当然。那是 you.com，这样就不会有人只打字母 U 了。
You.com. And yeah, check it out. Well, thank you all for being on the show. It's been a great time. I've really enjoyed talking about this. And thank you to all our listeners for hanging with us another episode. And we'll see you next time
You.com。是的，去看看吧。好了，非常感谢大家来到节目。这是一段美好的时光。我真的很享受谈论这个话题。也感谢所有和我们一起度过又一期节目的听众朋友们。我们下期再见。
music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I, and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
音乐由 Eric Barn Dollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音和改编，但你必须向帕特里克和我署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。